this video is sponsored attention all
ava pilots
ever heard of a game called dragon raja
because right now evangelion is having
an exclusive collab with them dragon
raja is a fantasy mmo rpg for the ios
and android and i mean i say it's for
mobile devices but just look at this
it runs on the unreal four engine and
you're essentially getting triple a
graphics right in the palm of your hand
it's a big fast download but the reason
for that speaks for itself
yes this game is the complete package
you've got a completely open world that
you can explore with your own
customizable character
make new friends make choices that
affect the story and there's even a
career system where you can be
anything you want they've even recently
just added a bunch of new systems as
well including a housing system a
marriage system and even an air system
yes find your perfect soulmate to build
a beautiful house together and then make
sweet babies and raise them up and of
course for a limited time they are doing
an evangelion collaboration
you can drive the evangelion test type
zero one to tour all the scenes in
dragon raja and also resist all the
angel attacks with your teammates that's
right what are you waiting for
get in the robot shinji and download
dragon raja today
click the link in the description to
give it a go right now
and with that said let's get on with the
video
winter 2021 was one of the greatest
seasons of anime we've had in years
we had a little bit of everything big
franchises small franchises the hype
shows everyone was talking about some
hidden gems it was the full
package honestly spring anime has some
big [ __ ] shoes to fill and
i'm sorry but being real i don't know
how you're gonna follow that
it's like having a boxing match just
after muhammad ali has left the ring i
don't care what shows you have or what
franchises you're coming back with like
what we got another season of my hero
some more isaikai shaman king remake
these can all turn out great and i'm
sure they probably will but
it doesn't matter what you throw at me
there is nothing left you can do
that's gonna surprise
this is the greatest anime season of all
time
where the [ __ ] does this fit on the fake
[Applause]
timeline
[Music]
are you gonna cry piss your pants maybe
maybe [ __ ] and come i do have to take a
step back sometimes and think to myself
you know from the outside looking in us
weebs must seem pretty weird sometimes
huh
like if i said hey want to see a tanned
smug anime girl call a socially awkward
guy a virgin for 20 minutes and then
mentally abuse him to the point of tears
most people would be like what why would
anyone find this entertaining
actually that sounds kind of mean and
then you look back to the anime
community and we're just like
the original manga artist to this
started off by drawing hinter and you
can absolutely tell cause this
just radiates dogen energy i mean [ __ ]
just look at this man she literally
invented a new facial expression
the smuggy gao this is the latest in the
line of smug [ __ ] teases defenseless
anime boy shows but this just takes it
up to 11.
this is uzaki-chan dark souls edition
this ain't even [ __ ] teasing anymore
it's just straight up psychological
warfare
i mean where do we go from here what's
next three thousand year old demon lolly
waterboards cancer patient
anime has gone full circle we've gone
from protect that smile to dear lord
above
please protect me from that smile this
is one of the most sadistic little shits
i've seen in anime whoever ends up
watching this must have some deep-rooted
masochism in them to enjoy this smug
little git verbally abusing them or
just want some anime girl to [ __ ]
step on them
anyway see you next episode look i know
i was meaning up in the opening of this
video but this is genuinely an amazing
[ __ ] season that came out of nowhere
so we're gonna go light on the memes
today because you know what
i've just got a lot of good shows i want
to talk about and i'm not even talking
about the sequels i mean like zombieland
saga is back so his sss
sss
ssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss
gesssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss
h this there's a freaking shaman king
remake i thought megalo box did
everything i needed to in season one but
holy [ __ ]
season two's darker and grittier
storyline is not what i expected but
it's shaping up to far exceed what we
had in the first season bruce
springsteen
now this one's definitely going to get
slept on i don't think that
anthropomorphized animals acting like
humans is a unique gimmick anymore but
this is nothing like your b stars or
regrets go i'm still trying to figure
out what this is but imagine a crime
mystery where dialogues and
conversations resemble something more
akin to a tarantino movie than it does
in anime that's reaching levels of vibe
i can't even begin to describe it is by
far one of the most unique shows airing
right now
it's just too bad because the season is
so stacked people are probably gonna
look over this
hmm let's see vivi floret isong oh cool
i'm up for an idle anime
[Music]
you know i've been doing these seasonal
rundowns for a fair few years now so i
can normally tell what shows are going
to be the big hitters so when i hear
about an anime original coming from
studio which written by reseries
creator involving a time travelling idol
cyborg going back to the past to prevent
an ai apocalypse starring lelouch as a
talking teddy bear that has great
animation amazing music
and an absolute banger first two
episodes it's gonna be one of the most
popular anime
of the season right
[Music]
what what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is it
doing all the way down here
somehow this is a hidden gem this season
and
i don't quite know how it's literally
terminator hatsune miku
it's detroit's become waifu i think a
lot of people ignored this because they
looked at the poster in the description
and thought this was just gonna be some
idle anime or something because i also
did initially until i clicked on the
first episode literally opening up to a
cyborg crushing a girl's skull with a
bare hand and i was like
guys look you know what re-zero is like
and this is looking to be just as brutal
and unforgiving as that
except this is way more action-packed
because god damn
i'm not an idol person or a cudary
person but bv kicks
[ __ ] ass in any other season this
would be one of the top shows so
i don't quite know what else to say go
watch it you degenerate
alright let's see what's next
[Music]
don't you [ __ ] dare you know when i
saw the premise for this anime was about
a mature
adult office worker taking in a runaway
underaged high school girl who's
offering her body for a place to stay i
was like oh
great is this gonna be one of those
[Music]
but thankfully this seems to be the
story of an honest-to-god respectable
guy trying to help out a younger girl
who seems lost in life right now
and it's cute and it's adorable and it's
wholesome and oh no her backstory's
gonna break me isn't it i've got high
hopes for this one i don't know if it's
gonna remain cute and lighthearted or
take a darker more serious turn
but i love the dynamic between these two
straddling between an older brother
sister relationship and a role model
father figure she never had
and as i say that i really hope it
doesn't usage dropped the ball if you
know what i'm saying
if you don't don't ask i just have to
trust that the main character keeps to
his morals as the mature
wise adult they've built him up as man
they've like really played up this
mature
old guy angle for this guy huh like he
can't be that old can he
oh he's 26.
oh hey look we've got another show about
an older guy and a younger girl i wonder
if this one's going to be as wholesome
as the other
kiss
[Music]
we've got another comedy isekai series
from the author of konasuba
featuring sci-fi kazuma and megamin
with a shotgun if you like super this
has the same punchy satirical dialogue
you'd expect from the author one thing
that always stands out is the chemistry
between the characters and their
interactions because one thing i can
respect is that he doesn't just resort
to poo poo stinky jokes for a laugh
i stand corrected you know there are
times in anime where you gotta sit back
and just laugh
at some of the stupid ridiculous [ __ ]
this medium comes up with sometimes but
other times you've gotta shut up stop
the jokes for a second and appreciate
when you've just experienced
something beautiful to your eternity is
one of those shows where you can feel
that
air of quality from the first few
minutes of pressing that play button
you know it's not going to take long for
this to cut deep and it
doesn't it draws you into this moving
tail this
gorgeous landscape the desolate
loneliness draped in an air of
melancholy in this beautifully
harsh snowy backdrop about a boy so
optimistically desperate to find his
family
to find anyone to rescue him from his
isolation
[Music]
get it
this packed more emotion into a single
20-minute episode than most anime do in
their entire season
there are shows that i feel are just
made to make you cry by showing you an
obviously sad situation
dead girl is dead dying girl is dying
this is a sad situation isn't it sad why
aren't you crying
but this feels something beyond just
your basic cry porn
the story the atmosphere the acting the
music the optimism the despair
it's such a beautifully crafted piece of
work that it leaves you with this
mess of emotions that you just don't
know how to handle properly you don't
just cry and move on
it sticks with you for the rest of the
day i didn't know this came from the
same writer as a silent voice and
honestly i don't think that matters at
all because the quality of this
spoke for itself add to this a surprise
hitaruta appears doing the theme song
and i think we are bearing witness to
something really special
regardless of whether every episode is
like this it's already done
more for me than most shows will do in
their entire
run 86 just might have the potential to
be the new political war mecca show
we've been waiting for
except this time we don't have the usual
bipedal robots but instead giant
[ __ ] off spider mechs with freaking
laser beams attached to their heads
that's right
it's code geass australia you've got a
country at war against autonomous
unmanned mechs a racist society that
treats anyone who's not pure blood as
sub-human
so much so that the soldiers on the
battlefield are treated as if they were
disposable robots controlled by the
pure-blooded commanders
except for our main girl who of course
is the only one who feels a true sense
of human loss whenever one of her unity
commands
dies in battle it's a truly horrific
situation to be in
which i absolutely empathize with
because i too have played fire emblem
once this is honestly looking pretty
[ __ ] good and the light novel it's
based on has won awards here in japan i
don't think we've had a fresh mecca
story like this since gundam space
africa and oh who's doing the music
again
oh wow i almost didn't recognize him i
really hope this is able to follow
through and give us the mecca war epic
we've been waiting for and so maybe
we'll actually have some good times
ahead especially for these guys right i
mean they absolutely deserve it
[ __ ] we've got another easy guy to add
to the mix this time in the most
delightful and happy of fancy world i
mean just listen to these delightful
cows
listen to these delightful sheep
listen to these delightful dogs but this
is a pretty cute series you've got our
main girl who's been reincarnated after
dying from overwork so all she wants to
do is to kick back and relax in this new
fantasy world and i get it especially
after all the things she's been through
all she wants to do is just to live a
quiet life without any stress or
distractions and just ends up casually
killing slimes every day for 300 years
to unintentionally become the most
powerful being in the world
this is basically just that south park
episodes where they kill pigs in wow she
keeps getting people trying to challenge
her who she brushes over easily because
she's just that damn powerful
i think this is just a fun light-hearted
series but i do wonder if she'll
actually find the one person in the
world who could possibly challenge her
tokyo avengers is another time travel
anime that from first impression seems
to be like delinquent
of race i'm gonna be honest i was
actually gonna gloss over this one
because even though the premise was
semi-interesting the adaptation itself
looked very
fun of the mill but this is one of those
titles where margaritas just
will not shut up about it apparently
it's meant to be really good with lots
of twists and turns so
you know what margaritas you win this
time all right i'll listen to you and
i'm going to give this one a shot but if
this turns out to be another erased i
swear to god
they're about to start
[Music]
i saw those snow white notes and thought
to myself yeah i'll probably give this
one a miss
i'm all about watching anime about niche
things but i think i've had my feel of
protagonist discovers insert niche hobby
here and joins the high school club of
in certainly shopping here and honestly
how can i even enjoy
insert niche hobby here if there's not a
bunch of cute anime girls doing it but
surprisingly this was way more adult
than i thought immediately opening up
with a plot about her struggling hostess
her [ __ ] cheating boyfriend
and the busy nightlife of tokyo you've
got a woman who our protagonist caused
mommy
baby and honestly so do i this is
looking a lot less like pretty boys do
shamans and things and more like nana
featuring your deception in february but
what took me by surprise
was the music performance i don't know
anything about the sharma son other than
it's some traditional japanese
instrument i'd see a random character
playing in the background of a samurai
movie every now and then
i've heard it before and being as
respectful as i can
it just didn't really sound like my
thing so here was our protagonist
about to play the sharmason in front of
an audience who were expecting a rock
concert and
my first thought was ah it's the cliche
where he wins over the audience that
we've seen many times before
okay go on i see what you're doing but
as soon as he started playing
something happened this simple
instrument commanded a presence i just
was not expecting and it immediately
sucks me in and did not let
go this wasn't just a cliche the
audience weren't just captivated because
the plots called for it
i was the audience and i was as silent
and lost in the music
as everyone else was in the crowd
somehow i started getting chills from a
make-believe performance for an
instrument
i didn't even think i liked i still
don't understand why this performance
was so captivating or why it made me
feel so many things
all i know is that it did i know many
people are gonna see this segment and
still come to the conclusion that yeah
this is not for them
but trust me even if you have no
intention of watching the entire series
just give episode 1 a shot
and maybe like me you'll discover
something new about yourself that you
never knew
before
[Applause]
[Music]
all right now play wonderwall
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
again i would like to thank today's
sponsor for making this video possible
if you liked what you saw with dragon
raja and would like to get involved in
the evangelion collaboration then hit
the link in the description to download
it today
honestly i saw this game and i thought
this looks way too [ __ ] good to be a
mobile game
and with that said also thank you very
much too
alpha sigma basil box dysfunctional
degenerate
elephant ivito payne patchett
the walto zob mondo and everyone else my
patreon for supporting me for this month
you know i'm gonna be real i
thought this season was gonna suck like
i looked at the chart before starting
the season and i was just like
that doesn't look like there's too many
good shows this season so [ __ ] me man i
hope you came out with as many surprises
as i did watching this video if you
hadn't been watching any shows because
my god i think i'm watching as many
shows as i did in winter and
i didn't actually think that was
possible yeah i don't know if 2020 was
sacrificed so that
2021 could be an absolute banging year
for anime but
so far this is shaping up to be one of
the greatest years of anime of all time
let's hope summer and four can live up
to the same expectations
anyway though that's it for now i'll
keep today short and sweet
no further updates from me i've been
giggup and i'll see you all
next time